[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai appris et en petits dés prover
plein de malice du genre fismois 10000
mal je te dirai qui tu es sur les genoux
de ma petite mémé qui loin d'être une
saucisse des crédits toujours tant que
c'est gratuit apathique et j'avoue
qu'elle m'enseignait des trucs un peu un
femme ne remet pas d'ma ce que tu peux
faire le sur la main qui voyage le
pas besoin d'amener sa femme et n'oublie
jamais ce judicieux petit refrain tous
pour un top a pas d'âge pour quoi il
mais moi les uns les autres
autrefois de lise et
comme dit ma concierge ou eugène y'a pas
de plaisir fait bien plus utile d'avoir
un diamant qu'une passoire et qui vaut
l'honneur
m'enfin cros appétit
il faut toujours se garder une soif pour
sa poire ne crois pas que celui qui paye
arlette de s'enrichir
il ne faut jamais juger les gens sur la
gamine
et pour rien au monde graisser la patte
un vin chaud pour les sept fois la
langue dans la bouche de sa voisine
il faut cependant battre son fer tant
qu'il est chaud pour un papa patins
[Musique]
ce n'est pas pareil
comme dit mon concierge ou bien gervais
n'y a pas de plaisir
il faut mieux disait tout le temps ma
mémé sucre d'orge dire du bien de sa
valise que la malle du voisin qui
connaissait ça mettra au pas un soutien
gorge comme dit l'autre on n'est jamais
trahi que par les siens
c'est quand le chat n'est pas là que les
10 en mai
mais il ne faut pas perdre de vue qu'on
a souvent
[Musique]
un plus petit qu'eux
fricassée la queue
10ème des gnons récoltera toujours des
dents tous pour un papa de pathos pour
moi effet mois les uns les autres
[Musique]
mise j'ai coupé
comme dit mon concierge julien germé n'y
a pas de plaisir
maintenant je suis grand j'ai acquis de
l'expérience moi aussi j'aimais dicton
pour et de vérité
c'est dans les vieux pots que la soupe
est la plus
et s'étant forgé en tout redevient
vachement fatigué c'est parfois les
petits qui font les grandes maîtresses
et les petits oiseaux vient
entretiennent les saletés frappe
toujours un homme à terre avant qu'il se
redresse
remerciera pour vivre heureux vivons
coucher tous
[Musique]
en effet moi les uns des autres
venise à paris comme dit ma concierge ou
eugène y'a pas de plaisir
[Musique]